meow welcome to this video five-minute
blitz and um deform e6 plate now I play
this this line the carers defense so
quite a quite interesting way to play
against deform well skies just um
developing normally just a plain healthy
moves doing nothing i'm fancy here under
me suddenly also a sensible approach
yeah it turned out to be kind of a dutch
defense went along castle system it's
remarkable people play a play this
rather often in positions where it
simply ever it's not called for um ok so
how to to go about that 94 go on just d6
at some complete development IAM he can
go g5 but I've got 94 us a good response
I want to play this developing moves
first and then see how to go about his
long castle in here okay let's see if i
can get this night we foreign term i can
notify for what don't know
well just continue developing him and
one point them that black n try to play
for is a 6b five a 6b five on other
forms of b5 to get them to get at the
king queen is happiness just completing
development and connecting rooks yeah
okay you can just win the spawn now and
probably white has some it doesn't have
enough compensation so just the edge
from it's hard to believe that this
should there should be enough but of
course it split some people will throw
the kitchen sink so what now bishop I'd
like to play Bishop before of course get
them get the bishops off very safe
choice it would take take win takes and
then Queen f5 getting getting Queens off
but I don't know it's a it looks looks a
bit unambitious Knight f6 is also an
interesting news but this I know he may
replace f3 after that f3 ng form and I
don't know if I want to take a 3 after
f3 come on I play let's play this play
the safely it's not the reputation of
the spawn sacrifice
but it's um it's a solid choice doesn't
even take it i mean okay then then I am
exchange what is the point g-form I
don't know gphone if a hard time to
understand down the ideas ephi v4 maybe
this was the idea of rupee adium of
course you can do that so okay try if I
didn't really pay attention to that and
rook age five and maybe I can answer
with a form what this looks really weird
yeah that was this was stupid I should
have firm taking this into account of
course very unnecessary to give him this
chance I was just a pawn up for not much
I know we started getting getting it
back
yeah maybe I can can can do the same it
takes e4 take G form and e forse I'm a
point where can I cannot take to take I
take this bone of course this wasn't
planned or anything I just overlooked
through gates five unfortunately right
now Queenie for would be very nice of
course getting hit getting the Queen's
off jack so on here yeah come on play
quickly keep before attacked and on this
I can take
you
here what is he doing now takes on e
Pfeiffer cannot really be the solution
maybe g5 okay group the ATM so the
threat the nidus sir very nicely placed
here 280 and some c4 is also week some
location this is some this end game is
swooning simply with the structure the
night stopping two pawns anthem I've got
here to two bonds on the on the King
side so lets them use of the rook yeah
the night s sir the hero of this
position blocking two pawns and killing
off this bishop so on just grade
King to e forum can go to your form
so on how to proceed now I can I can do
that g5 next
yeah this wasn't the most precise way
King d5 for some bit annoying and I can
play wiki 8 it's probably still alright
but thirdly had to have more convincing
ways yeah let's stop King d5 once and
for all to know there are two connected
passes right yeah I know I'm not quite
satisfied with with the technical play
here that I that I let him watch him in
maybe am I just I need to go rook t8
maybe this is much simpler taking the d
file so that the King cannot approach
yeah lets just hear and now I've got
I've got the depot at the default
completely completely covered so the
King cannot approach and then I can
simply prepare to advance the points
this is just like having two extra
points as the e pawns are simply not on
the board just h6 king h7 g5 King g6 and
they're rolling my engine here only
gives black want one point extra which
is quite funny this is really completely
winning yeah thanks for watching